it is time for Benedict Cumberbatch to
meet Benedict Cumberbatch Madame
Tussauds no what are they called a wax
figure they're not wax work the wax
figures all right yeah okay and you
haven't met it yet no right so come with
me come on come over here all right
everyone come over have a look have a
look have a look
so this is gonna be spooky so come down
here come down here okay you're all set
yeah okay yeah yeah here is better to
come back feast your eyes on you
this is day
no it looks so like you that's spooky
he's tired even it's as tired as I feel
oh yeah do it do it do it yeah yeah nice
nice
we all come in not a picture taken with
this mm-hmm yeah you can photo bomb must
be huh
okay
take a run up ready okay camera a over
there somewhere
ready okay one two three
[Applause]
okay you in the next Star Trek no
comment
okay
[Applause]